SPEAKER 1: Hey, I'm Jens.
I'm the senior rendering
engineer for Crytek,
and I'm here to share a
bit of the experience what
happens when you drop
Robinson on a mobile phone.
Robinson is actually
a VR game that
is about a little boy
stranded on a planet.
And we published that
in 2016 for PS VR,
and then later for fro
HTC Vive and Oculus Rift.
So they're actually very
different platforms.
The PS4 has the
UMA architecture,
just like a mobile phone.
And the other ones are PC.
We had NUMA versus
UMA differences
built into the engine.
So when we tackled working
on the mobile phone,
we didn't have to change very
much to get optimal streaming
and stuff like that, because
memory management is very
important, and you
don't want to copy
stuff around which you already
have in your mobile device.
For us, it was basically
a learning experience.
We had the hope to support
GVR with Vulkan, which wasn't
the case back then at GDC 2017.
And still today, Vulkan has no
connection to any VR interface
at the moment.
The Android system
part of the Cry engine,
we did need to touch,
because in 2015, for GDC,
we made an equally
quick and dirty hack
for our Crysis 3 MP--
multi-player on a Tegra device.
That Tegra device was
much more powerful
than an Android mobile device,
and it ran on an open [? GN. ?]
So basically that was an
exercise in orientation
and evaluating how was the
performance of the GPU, what
are the tools that we have,
and how we can improve on that.
And I brought the demo.
So this is an S7 Edge.
I think it runs at 1920 by 1080.
And this is our loading screen.
And this is a sequence from
the beginning of the game.
It's obviously not VR
because we don't want to--
we had-- we don't
have the capability
to write everything, which is
in the regular Oculus driver,
both [INAUDIBLE] Chronos
missions, and hair tracking,
and all of this which we
would have to make ourselves,
which obviously is possible.
By default, it's
on [? rayint, ?]
and you can't hear
it sadly, but it
actually Hicks, which was
this little AI in the boy
with AI is talking
to us, and there
are sounds in the background,
and for fun, we also made it--
this is very difficult to see--
made it react to the
orientation of the cell phone.
It's kind of sad,
but I mean, you
can come forward after
the talk, and then
you can try it yourself.
It's not a big deal.
As you saw, It runs
about 45 frames
per second, sometimes
a bit better,
or sometimes a bit worse.
We also experimented
with a Nexus 6P
which was, I would say, a
failure in the Samsung S7.
This is a version with an
Exynos, and a Mali T880.
And the Nexus 6P
has an Adreno chip
which has severe limitations.
So it didn't work out very well.
OK, so regarding Vulkan, we
reworked the entire Cryengine
over the last years
to be more abstract.
Initially, it was
entirely DX11 models,
so even the GL renderer that
we used on the Tegra device
was actually a DX11
to OpenGL translation.
So this time we made everything
abstract in all the APIs
that we are supporting, like 11
and 12, and Vulkan, and so on.
It's natively integrated, and
has all the optimizations--
PS4, Xbox, and so on.
So this was not our
first attempt at Vulkan.
Our PC version ran relatively
stable at that time,
but it was our first attempt.
And we're running Vulkan
on a mobile device.
Our Android approach is SDL,
the open source project,
and there was no Vulkan
support at that time.
So I ripped out the entire
default OpenGL context
initialization, which
happens by default,
and used our regular Vk
surface and Vk swap-chain,
a function ID that we had to
create the necessary Vulkan
objects to run on
an Android window.
When we ran it just like
that, a lot of bad things
happened, and no validation
errors were generated.
In the introspection
when we tried
to find out what happened
on the Adreno chip,
it only supported four
descriptor tables per stage,
and stuff like that, without
any validation error when you
turn on the validation data.
Besides that, there
were tons of formats
which were not supported.
I mean, Robinson ran on
the regular PC GPUs, which
all support block compression.
So we had to find
corresponding mappings to EAC.
Luckily the [? S ?] [? block ?]
[? field ?] was already
in place because our OpenGL
implementation had all the EAC
codings enabled.
Then there were some
surprising fails.
There were specific
SNORM targets
which were [? unavailable. ?]
We mapped them
to half float formats.
There were some, I think,
[INAUDIBLE]---- both.
I'm not sure which of them
didn't support 32-bit float--
depth stencil.
Then we had to go back to a D16.
There was also a problem
getting something
as basic as a [? RAD16, ?]
which was in the Tegra format--
single-channel in
Tegra format, which
would actually alias the D16.
So we had problems
actually accessing this D16
by aliasing the [INAUDIBLE].
We didn't pick ASTC
over EAC because we just
worked one month on it.
[CHUCKLING]
And it was just an
experiment, so it's not that.
But we have to make the
whole feature list complete.
So basically we ran
through the code
and made a large part of
the code base flexible.
There was the situation
where the [? regressive ?]
swap-chain mode of
FIFO wasn't available,
and we had to get to mailbox.
There was a situation that
you ask for trigger buffering,
and so that you get
three big buffers,
and you actually got four.
There was the problem with
the specific texture formats,
and like for example
the Mali T880 on this S7
doesn't have
anisotropic filtering.
On the Adreno, we don't have
any cube arrays or 3D samplers,
and when the geometry
shader and tesselation
support is all over
the place, most of them
basically don't support any of
that, and there's a problem--
if you're from a
PC environment, you
know that you always
can bind Adreno targets,
and you basically have
unlimited descriptors,
and/or you have 256 HLSA or
shader slots, and all of this
is--
the numbers are not very large.
Most of the time it's
four [? inner ?] targets.
Sometimes you have,
because of a [INAUDIBLE]
run descriptor table, sometimes
you have three descriptor
or four descriptor tables.
So you have to keep
the engine running
on all of these restrictions,
and just not quit and say, oh,
sorry, you can't run.
That is not
necessarily a problem
to allow the system to
downcast the swap-chain modes.
That's not a big deal if
you're using FIFO or mailbox,
or something like that.
You can write your code
so that the texture
formats can downcast competitor
formats that are available.
It's just you have to make a
lot of reflection on the device,
and see what you can do.
In the case if you
really need a 3D texture,
it becomes a bit
complicated, but I
mean, having
alternatives available--
algorithmic alternatives--
is always a good thing.
Our shaders are a lot.
We have 45,000
lines of HLSL code.
So when we supported
the OpenGL, we
had a transcoder
that translated HLSL
to GLSL, which was HLSLCC, which
was also used in [? Unity. ?]
We heavily modified it.
We added compute shader
support, and all kinds
of different simpler
types of [? fonts, ?]
and so on, so that the thing
became feature complete
in the end, basically.
The problem is that on the
Vulkan, GLSL is not GLSL.
On the Vulkan, GLSL is
a Vulkan-specific GLSL
with different imitations
and difference syntaxes,
and so I had to go over
HLSLCC again, and make
a lot of adjustments, like
how to pass metadata from HLSL
to SPIR-V, because you want
to reflect on the SPIR-V.
Basically this is an
exercise in [INAUDIBLE]
So luckily this is over
because now we have,
I think it's called DXC or DBC.
We have a native HLSL
to SPIV-V translator
which has been developed
by Chronos together
with a few folks of Google.
So this is not anymore.
We don't repeat that.
So we ran into a lot of
early adopter issues,
even after we thought we
make everything right,
and we adapt to all the
different parameters
of these devices.
Like we said, on the PC, it ran.
There were no validation
errors on the devices.
errors, but sometimes it
was completely broken, or it
looked slightly different.
Specific parts of it
looked different-- flickers
or some constant
buffer, or they just
weren't transferred to the
draw in the correct way
or something like that.
We don't know really
what happened there.
So on the Adreno,
like I said, there
was absolutely
keymap array support,
so we limit that to one cubemap.
There were problems with
the constant buffers,
so we actually made big
areas in the shaders
where we had coded lines, like
for example, for this demo.
This is not because of
performance reasons.
This is really because
the device or the driver
just didn't do what
we told them to do.
And then there was
a problem on Adreno
which was relatively severe.
We couldn't actually
target descriptor tables,
so we bound one monstrous
descriptor table,
and we dynamically offset
it with every [? draw ?]
[? core, ?] which is a
solution on several--
basically all of these solutions
just to make the demo running.
I cannot recommend that
you try something like that
for delivering a game.
So after it ran with
the expected result,
the next problem
was performance.
Well, this is Robinson,
which means that our baseline
performance is a PS4.
And the subsequent releases
on Steam and on the Oculus
were for PCs, which
means open-ended.
You can run it on Titan,
so there were no problems.
This is a comparison
between an S7 and a PS4,
which is in some
ways very severe.
Here the CPU is an Exynos
MP12, which is a 2.3 gigahertz
four-core.
It runs in big.LITTLE,
I think, so in theory we
could have eight, but
we could only use four.
These gigaflops
are without Neon.
Neon is a vectorization
instruction
for [? ARM, ?] which,
if you would use it,
would quadruple the gigaflops,
which means you would be at 9.2
versus 102.4 gigaflops.
In this demo it's not
such a big problem
because we don't have
any collision detection.
We don't have any
complex CPU code.
But if you would actually
try to calculate any of that,
some problems would occur.
The GPU is in a
similar ballpark.
The Mali T880 has 260
gigahertz versus 1.8 teraflops
of the PS4.
Basically these gigaflops don't
necessarily mean that much.
You also have
[? theorate ?] limitations.
You have [? throughput ?]
limitations, and so on.
So this is just like a
rough idea [? about ?] this.
The biggest problem, actually,
even if it doesn't really
look like that, is
the memory bandwidth.
On the PS4, we have a GEDDR
5 [? shared ?] [? piece ?]
between the CPU and GPU, and
on the S7, we have LDP DDR4,
which is a low-power DDR4, which
is actually [? the bitrate, ?]
so it's 28.7 gigabytes per
second versus was 176 gigabytes
per second and this--
because we're having-- we're
implementing deferred shading.
We have a lot of
post-processing effects
which are full-screen effects.
The cost of everything
after the GBuffer
is proportional
to the resolution.
And the bandwidth cost is
proportional to the resolution
as well.
So you can run a
very small resolution
and run the whole pipeline
or you have to make cuts.
And then, there are
the thermal issues,
which we completely ignored.
But this device
behaves very nice.
The [? take-around ?] that we
ran three years ago was running
hot after five minutes
and was throttling,
which didn't happen with
this, which was pretty nice.
So the rendering
framework of Robinson
is [INAUDIBLE] deferred shading.
Pipeline.
We're running
GBuffer pass, which
means all the drawers are
writing out material attributes
into different render targets.
And we are storing depth.
And then afterwards, we can
do all kinds of magic things
with it, like AO, screen
space AO, or the lighting,
or depth of field, motion blur.
All of these things can
be done on this GBuffer.
Here, we have three
[? bound ?] render targets.
Each one is [INAUDIBLE]
8-bit, which
means we have about 24
bites in 3 render targets.
And it's relative
[? filler rate ?] heavy.
It gives us a lot of the
capacities of the [INAUDIBLE]..
And if you look at the pure
memory bandwidth occupation,
just looking at
it, that's about--
almost a gigabyte per second.
You can just look 28
times [? and set your ?]
buffer on a mobile
device, and then you
eat up all your bandwidth.
So that is pretty problematic.
That is just one 2560 by 1440.
So we had to find
an alternative.
In the beginning,
we experimented
with 4-bit render targets.
These are 8-bit
render targets that
would then go to 12, 12-bit.
But we still would be
[INAUDIBLE] because we still
have three render targets bound.
So our idea was we reduced
the entire three render target
GBuffer to a single
4-component render target.
In a previous
version of crisis--
[COUGHING]
Excuse me.
We already employed
a technique that we
are storing some
information just on even
and [? alternating ?]
information
on odd pixels, which resides
in the half-size rendering.
Not a quarter-size rendering,
but a half-size rendering.
Here, we store albedo
at full resolution.
So the basic non-metallic
surface color
is full resolution.
And then, we are storing normal
smoothness and reflectance
at [? alternating ?]
positions, like you'll
see in the little square there.
The reflectance is non-color.
We could get away
with it in this demo,
but normally you
would actually want
to have color to reflectance,
which needs more time.
So we just wanted to
see, how fast could we
get CRYENGINE running
without major modifications?
Can we actually get into the
direction of VR performance?
So here, we have examples
of this tiny micro GBuffer.
So there are the
three render targets.
The upper one is the rgb
part and the lower one
is the a part.
So really, just
three render targets.
And everything, all these
six things, are in those two.
If you zoom a bit
nearer, you see the cost.
The cost is that--
of course, you're
under-sampling your edges.
You sometimes see that every
even/odd line just forms
a diagonal, except--
instead of like the
regular diagonal
that you have in the
full-resolution GBuffer.
The meaning of the
[? alternating ?] pixels
here is also not
always the same.
So it's a bit difficult
to label this.
It's just that you get the
idea of what's the price.
We actually have an edge
where reconstruction
of this in the
lighting [? pass, ?]
it comes out in
acceptable quantity.
In other areas,
like we render HDR.
And we [? tone up ?]
the HDR later.
The bandwidth savings
we reach by reducing
the precision of the HDR
buffer from regular halves
to 11-bit halves.
Even lower precision floating
point representations.
We kicked [? stencil ?] out so
that we could use D16 instead
of [? D24S8. ?]
And Robinson as a VR
game, already provides
a lot of effects.
We don't have depth of field.
We don't have motion blur
because all of this stuff just
in the VR environment breaks
the illusion that you are really
in the scene.
It breaks immersiveness.
So we had to turn off a lot
of the additional nice-making
post-processing effects, like
the subsurface scattering
because it requires
space in the GBuffer.
We also don't have any
screen space reflection
because it eats way
too much bandwidth.
It's basically ray tracing
rays in screen space, which
probably eats up the entire
bandwidth that we have.
No volumetric fog.
That's a 3D texture.
Back then, we wouldn't
have had an alternative,
like two-dimensional fog
or something like that.
Like I said, of all the
other [INAUDIBLE] effects,
we only needed tone mapping
and the vignette effect,
so that you have the simulation
of a reduced field of view.
And we made one uber
shader out of that,
which looking at
the bandwidth is,
I think, the correct
suggestion that you merge
all your post-processing,
all your screen space
passes, if possible,
into one big shader
because the [? ALU ?]
capacity of the mobile GPU
is way above the bandwidth.
So instead of read/write,
read/write, read/write,
it's better to just
read once, and then
drop 5,000 instruction shader,
and then only write once.
All right.
So our conclusion of the project
regarding games on Android.
The effort to make Vulkan run on
the mobile platform from our PC
platform was
relative [? minor. ?]
We were four people
working one month on it.
So you could basically say
one of us worked one month
on polishing all the problematic
cases of Vulkan on mobile.
The biggest problem is the
variety of targetable hardware.
Like we had in the
talks before, you
can make a business
decision, like it's not
viable to target this
and that much hardware.
But as a software
engineer, you also
have the problem there's
tons of hardware,
which is almost equivalent.
And there's just one
checkbox missing, or here's
just one checkbox missing.
So you have to write your
engine relative flexible
that you can adapt
yourself to it.
We also didn't really believe if
we would render this in stereo,
then we would be at
20 fps maybe, which
is way below what is supportable
by a [? personal ?] VR device.
But if you didn't really
expect that to happen.
But basically, if we
have GPU that is twice
as powerful as a
[INAUDIBLE],, then we actually
might get into the direction
of having something like this
in VR on a mobile device.
We were very happy
that in principle, it
was possible to run a fully
physically-based shading
pipeline on the mobile device
with actual [INAUDIBLE]
deferred rendering
and forward plus.
And while I didn't observe
any compute queue in Vulkan
on any of these
tested devices, I'm
pretty sure that the modern
mobile devices are coming up
with a compute queue
earlier than later.
Vulkan is very well-positioned
because the CPU overhead
is very low.
You have a lot of possibility
to control your GPU performance.
You can submit stuff
in different ways.
That's contrary to openGL,
which is a very large black box.
It's difficult to
optimize for it.
Because I mean, the
driver can make something,
and then you don't
know about it.
And everything you
did was in vain.
While for Vulkan, everything
is relative well-defined.
The conclusion for
Vulkan on Android.
Well, I already
announced a few of those.
The good part is that
in Vulkan, you can
do multi-threader rendering.
Our entire renderer is actually
submitting the big scene
graphs in a multi-threaded way.
This is very, very
difficult in openGL.
You can open
concurrent contexts,
but I wouldn't suggest it.
It's probably not worth it.
What's very nice is
actually, the renderer
sub-passes of Vulkan, which
requires huge refactoring
of your engine.
It basically means that
little tiles of your shader
run once through
the whole process.
Let's say you have 10 passes.
So then, this tile
is run 10 times.
And then, another tile is
run 10 times, and so on.
So you are having the
possibility in the driver
to actually merge parts of
that using optimal memory I/O
and stuff like that.
But that requires
making dedicated changes
in the architecture.
So at the end, I want to thank
everyone who participated.
Alex, myself, Theo, Mathjs,
Nico, and the other Nico.
And without the guys
working on these tools,
almost nothing of this
would have been possible.
HLSLcc is an open
source project, which
we could manipulate, give back.
Spirv-cross is, I
think, from Khronos now.
SDL2, standard stuff
since [INAUDIBLE]..
And we have properly used a few
more open source tool chains
to make all this weird
stuff happen where we don't
have any official support.
And special thanks to Lei
Zhang and Ehsan Nasiri,
who are actually
from Google, I think.
They are working on the DXC,
which is this new SPIR-V
backend which removes all
the problematic things
with shaders.
Crytek is hiring.
So if you want to work on
mobile for the CRYENGINE,
write us an email.
Questions?
AUDIENCE: Question about
the [INAUDIBLE] mentioned.
Because it looks to
me that most of--
some of your bandwidth
problems could
be alleviated by not spilling
the tile after every pass.
And you mentioned that
that would require
a retexturing of the engine.
Is that a problem of
resources in a sense
that it could take you a long
time to [INAUDIBLE] the engine?
Or is it a problem
of the API that
is not making your life easier?
SPEAKER 1: No.
The problem is that the last
missing piece in the CRYENGINE
is that we don't
have render graph.
The big API makers are
evangelizing the idea
that you submit the whole
framework as a render graph.
And if you generate the render
graph dynamically every frame,
like you don't write
the render graph in code
in your [? CPP ?]
and it's static.
If you have a manager
that generates a render
graph every frame to
schedule all of this,
then you can actually generate
render sub-passes for Vulkan
automagically because
you have to specify,
OK, this is an input.
Which status this
input is [INAUDIBLE]..
Is this cleared?
Do I read from it?
Is it a [INAUDIBLE]
write, and so on?
So you have to annotate
a lot of the [INAUDIBLE]
that you use generating
sub-passes in Vulkan.
And it's not recommendable
to make this manually.
So you have to have
an automated system
to generate render graphs
in data, in memory.
And then, it's a
[? trivial ?] thing.
AUDIENCE: So it's
a high-level issue?
SPEAKER 1: Yes, it's
a high-level issue.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
And then, move
onto the next tile?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, that's
even independent.
In Vulkan, you have
the possibility--
like what we saw in
these capture tools,
you had the render
targets where you write to
and you have the
depth [INAUDIBLE]..
And if you express something
at sub-passes in Vulkan,
you're basically
describing a chain
of shaders, how they
interact with each other,
how they are feeding
data from one shader
pass to a next shader pass.
It's similar to how we
describe at the shader
stages between vertex
shader and pixel shader,
and how they're interacting
with each other in the data
transportation way.
So on Vulkan, you have
one step above that.
So that you are basically
putting entire [? drawers ?]
into relation to subsequent
[? draws. ?] And that brings
a lot of performance.
Can potentially bring
a lot of performance,
like we have the imagination
ships, which are actually
ships which have hardware
support for this mechanism.
So it doesn't spill to memory.
We have this problem
that LPDDR4 is very slow.
So the imagination ship
has an [INAUDIBLE] buffer,
where he spills the data between
the different sub-passes,
not into main memory.
He spills into a special,
dedicated piece of hardware.
And you can maybe get away
with 10 times speedup by that.
The bandwidth of this
internal area of the chip
is 10 times faster than LPDDR4.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
texture formats.
Did you guys use ETC2, or did
you find that not sufficient?
I mean, in [? SATC. ?]
SPEAKER 1: No.
For is, it's not sufficient.
We are almost using every
texture format under the sun.
AUDIENCE: I believe that's the
only one across all Android.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
No, there are weird
permutations of ETC2,
which provide one-channel,
two-channel, and additional bit
depths until 11-bit.
And we are using all
of those [INAUDIBLE]..
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And are
you going to continue
with your experimentation?
Are you going to wait for mobile
to get a little bit better?
SPEAKER 1: Maybe it
depends on how fast
openXR is going to finalize.
There's an initiative from
Khronos called openXR, which
encapsulates openAR,
openMR, and openVR, where
they want to attach Vulkan to.
And then, we have a
real VR interface.
And then, we definitely are
[? back ?] experimenting.
The problem for us is the
gap between the PS4, which
is our regular [? min ?] spec,
and the next mobile device.
AUDIENCE: It's great to see you
working with our open source
teams on the shader
compiler stuff.
On the validation errors you
were seeing with the device
physical limits, have
you submitted an issue
to the open source GitHub
project for the Vulkan
validation layers?
There's a GitHub project for
Vulkan validation layers.
SPEAKER 1: All right.
AUDIENCE: And you were saying
they were not catching issues
with physical limits?
SPEAKER 1: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Have you submitted
a bug to that GitHub project?
SPEAKER 1: No, because the
state of the Adreno driver
was so shaky, that we
didn't expect any--
well, OK.
I understand that the validation
layer is a different part
from the driver.
But for us, it's not
transparent if we
[? fault ?] the validation layer
or we [? fault ?] the driver.
But this is one year ago, right?
Even on the PC, the
validation layer
was not firing for some
stuff which was obvious.
And then half a
year ago, there was
a moment where the validation
layer fired too much.
And now, we have a moment
where the validation layer
is probably in a good place.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
SPEAKER 1: Regarding the PC
validation layer problems,
I think we submitted
bug reports.
AUDIENCE: They
should be unified.
So whatever you're seeing on PC
should work on Android as well.
SPEAKER 1: OK.